mind your decisions I'm fresh tell
Walker recently a test in Singapore is
causing a lot of backlash and it even
left some students in tears the test was
for 12 year olds in Singapore and I want
to go over one of the more challenging
problems and explain how to solve it
start with five semi circles that are
alternatingly
up and down these are the distances
between the semi circles if all five
semi circles are identical what is the
diameter of one semi circle pause if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
there are a couple of ways you can
approach the problem I approach it using
algebra suppose this distance is X by
symmetry this distance on the other side
of the diagram will also be X now label
this distance as Y and by symmetry this
distance will also be equal to Y now
let's consider the length of this
diameter it's equal to 22 plus X here
we'll have another expression for the
diameter it'll be X plus 12 plus y we
have two different ways to express the
diameter so they're equal to each other
we then cancel out the X terms and then
simplify this equation we end up that Y
is equal to 10 we then focus on the
central semicircle and then substitute
in for y and then we get 10 plus 16 plus
10 which gives us our answer that the
diameter is equal to 36 this is an
algebraic approach but twelve-year-old
students would have actually considered
a different geometric approach let's
focus on these two semi circles now
let's imagine rotating this entire
diagram
notice that this distance will also be
equal to 22 therefore when we subtract
12 from it we're left with a distance of
10 the same thing goes for the other two
semi circles on the other half of the
diagram we now go back to the original
diagram and we focus on the central
semicircle we have 10 plus 16 plus 10
and that again gives us the diameter of
36 interesting I think this problem is
easy if you know what approach to take
but it would be tricky on a timed exam
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]